[Music]
this morning on the dish a visit to
snake
river farms if you're looking for the
best beef in the land
a ranch in northern washington right
near the canadian border is a good place
to start
snake river farms is an american pioneer
of wagyu
a style of meat that first came from
japan famous for its exceptional
marbling
the taste is incredible prices can be
too
but ask those who are hooked and they'll
say it's well worth it
to see how it works we traveled west to
see the farm
and sample a feast
now this smith and wolenski in chicago
steak is the main feature of the menu
but this
is no ordinary meat and it doesn't come
from any ordinary place
the remote town of loomis in northern
washington state
has become a coveted destination for
chefs restaurant owners
and ranchers worldwide why
the product from snake river farms a
marble delicacy the company has elevated
into an art form
robert rebholtz is the ceo the goal was
always to try to take it a level above
usda prime
and the wagyu breed allows that to
happen
because right now chefs say to you prime
is not enough
correct this is peter kallisher near
kobe japan
as a herd of the most pampered cattle in
the world
come in from a morning constitutional on
the open range
modern wagyu beef originated in the
mid-19th century
when the japanese began crossbreeding
native cattle with cows imported from
europe
much of the hoopla then was about the
cows receiving
beer and massages about 2 000 of these
especially coddled cattle
go to market every month and no doggy
heading for the last roundup ever had it
so good
robert's father brought in a handful of
bulls before the japanese band
exports of wagyu cattle in the 1990s
using those bulls he began a breeding
program crossing wagyu with
american angus rebels senior died young
at just 57. his son just 33 at the time
was put in charge chefs come here to
learn what
they learn a lot about what it takes
behind the scenes to produce the quality
we do
i think and when they do it they also
learn about our industry
wagyu take longer to grow and need
higher quality feed
which means they cost more but americans
have been buying
a lot of it traced back to an
outrageously priced
hamburger in 2003 and the media frenzy
that followed
and he recently added a unique hamburger
to the menu but there is a catch it's
going to cost you
41. one of my favorite steaks
is the snake river farm celebrity chefs
like wolfgang puck became advocates for
wagyu
and snake river with a steak like that
you don't need
a lot of seasoning you want the flavor
of the meat
let's go round them up let's do it the
ranching operation we visited may look
run-of-the-mill at first here we go nice
and easy
it is not it actually looked like you're
moving the cows
i was but like purposely it's
interesting because most people think of
this as an old school endeavor
there are new age things that happen
here right
yeah totally so the speed in which we've
been able to
make better decisions on quality is
accelerate a lot with
improvements like embryo transfers
artificial insemination it allows
ranches to really focus and fine-tune
their genetics around the higher
producing well-marbled sires
part of the genetic process happens at
the company's bold development center
outside boise
breeding is either natural or uses
artificial insemination
each bull is carefully tracked and
sharded as are their progeny
to ensure its lineage from the original
japanese cows
and wagyu stands for hua is japanese goo
is cattle literally means japanese
cattle
leah schultz is the bull development
manager here
how do you keep cows happy fresh water
good feed smile on your face okay
there is no beer or massaging for the
animals now
just a closed-loop system that allows
the company to protect every part of the
process
trying to ensure the healthiest possible
fertilization
pregnancies and calves you stress an
animal out it's no different than
a human or myself like if there's a lot
going on
if i'm stressed out do i want to eat no
do i want to drink not necessarily am i
going to lose weight
yeah probably so it's the exact same
thing in cattle
the bulls in this pen are getting ready
to be sent out for the first time
what guys what's the problem we're just
trying to say hi
they can smell new york that's the whole
boy
all right go to work over the last
several years
snake river has dramatically expanded
its push into e-commerce
selling its beef like this gold rib-eye
not just to high-end restaurants but
directly to consumers
tenderness-wise it's pretty much like
the inner one flavor-wise though it's
it's the best so it's best of both
worlds
basically kent clarke
is the mild-mannered lead cowboy in
loomis
and a cooker of super steaks
that's incredible it's good it takes
seven years from the time the first
genetic decision is made
until the result winds up on your plate
right now
only half of one percent of the beef
eaten nationwide is
wagyu quality if the snake river success
story continues
the landscape may look a lot different a
generation from now
how much of it for you is trying to sell
the story
of snake river farms or just saying
we're going to do the best product and
whatever we do people are going to find
it if it's good it's more of the product
quality
so that's when the word of mouth really
picks it that's what it is though
it is and it's a lot of fun to see that
happen i mean you're not running super
bowl ads
no right you can't afford to
[Laughter]
one thing i hear from a lot of folks is
you know they buy a steak at their local
supermarket which can be decent it's
fine
they try snake river and it's just a
whole different
level um which i think it is now listen
it's not something every day necessarily
but special events special occasions and
and how do you pronounce it again
wagyu it's wagyu yeah okay japanese
cattle there it is